[Music]
on this wednesday night
a new chapter in america democracy has
prevailed
u.s president joe biden i will be a
president for
all americans and vice president kamala
harris
take the oath of office i will support
and defend
the constitution how history was made
the promises of unity and hope
and the intense security plus what
canada's political leaders think
is possible now and the young poet who
stole the show
we will raise this wounded world into a
wondrous one
also tonight seniors feeling snubbed
ageism
is showing its ugly head once again
complaint
some vulnerable canadians are not
getting vaccinated fast enough
global national with donna friesen
america has a new commander-in-chief and
he and first lady jill biden have
already moved into their new home
600 pennsylvania avenue a new era has
begun
at the white house president joe biden
is calling on americans to end
the uncivil war that he says is
fracturing the united states
and in the oval office he has already
signed a string
of executive orders just before noon
eastern biden was sworn in
as the 46th u.s president and kamala
harris shattered gender and racial
barriers to become
the first female vice president on a
sunny day
on the steps of the same building
stormed by a violent mob just two weeks
ago
the inauguration was peaceful protected
by thousands of troops
and a fortress of barriers
preserve protect and defend the
constitution of the united states
constitution of the united states so
help you god so help me god
congratulations mr president
[Applause]
good evening and thanks for joining us
the new president called it america's
day of history
and hope joe biden is turning the page
on the trump era
hours after being sworn in he got to
work signing more than 15
executive orders many of them undoing
what former president
trump did biden said america can once
again
become a leading force for good in the
world
this is america's day
this is democracy's day a day of history
and hope
of renewal and resolve today
we celebrate the triumph not of a
candidate
but of a cause the cause of democracy
at this hour my friends democracy has
prevailed
together we shall write an american
story
of hope not fear of unity not division
of light
not darkness may this be the story that
guides us
the story that inspires us and the story
that tells ages yet to come that we
answer the call of history
we met the moment democracy and hope
truth and justice did not die in our
watch but thrive
we have full coverage tonight including
what this new era in washington
might mean for canada but we begin with
our washington
bureau chief jackson proskow on the
moment and the message
from america's new president
he waited his whole career for this
moment congratulations mr president
joe biden likely never imagined it would
unfold like this
sworn in under a cloud of crisis to
govern a nation
rocked by mass death and political
instability
to all those who did not support us let
me say this
hear me out as we move forward take a
measure of me and my heart
if you still disagree so be it
that's democracy that's america
biden's pleas for unity were cast across
the void of an empty national mall
folks this is a time of testing
a space cordoned off over concerns about
domestic extremists and the pandemic
two crises that biden will work to solve
i promise you we will be judged
you and i by how we resolve these
cascading crises of our era
[Music]
the grim circumstances did not diminish
the history of this day
harrison with the swearing-in of the
first woman
and first woman of black and south asian
heritage as vice president
so help me god
history was also made by the absence of
the outgoing president
who spurned the inauguration and refused
to even utter
biden's name before leaving washington
have a good life
we will see you soon politics doesn't
have to be a raging fire
destroying everything in his path biden
likewise avoided any mention of trump
but condemned the defining features of
his presidency
we must reject the culture in which
facts themselves
are manipulated and even manufactured
and i pledge this to you i will be a
president for
all americans all americans
[Applause]
and i promise you i will fight as hard
for those who did not support me
as for those who did
unity did not preclude a quick break
from his predecessor
the new president set about signing a
flurry of executive orders
blocking the keystone xl pipeline
rejoining the paris climate accord
stopping the construction of trump's
border wall and mandating face masks on
federal property
jackson joe biden has a massive job
ahead
president trump former president trump
now always attacked the media as the
enemy of the people
and he used twitter as his personal
bullhorn i'm wondering what approach joe
biden is going to take to communicating
his message
donna he's likely to be much more
traditional than trump was we're not
expecting biden to hire and fire people
over twitter or make policy
announcements that way
instead we're expecting a return to the
use of the white house briefing room
with daily briefings by the press
secretary
in other words as traditional as it can
get for a president
okay jackson proskow in washington
tonight thanks
late today the biden administration said
the president will be calling prime
minister justin trudeau on friday
and while he was signing executive
orders in the oval office late today
biden confirmed donald trump left him a
letter in the desk biden said it was a
very
generous letter and because it is
private he won't talk about it until
he's able to talk
to trump there can be no bragging about
the size of the crowds for this
inauguration because there were no
crowds instead american flags were
planted in the national mall
representing
the thousands of americans who couldn't
be there because of the pandemic
and the intense security because of the
fear of domestic terrorism
our mike armstrong was on the streets
during the transfer of power that was
peaceful
and quiet
the opportunities for the public to see
any part of this inauguration day
were few and far between and unofficial
from this street two blocks north of the
white house people turned up to watch
president trump leave the white house by
helicopter
for the last time i just had to see it
for myself
let him leave i wouldn't believe it if
he if i didn't see it for myself
i just would have a hard time believing
it a few blocks away
just a half hour later another
unofficial and fairly long distance
chance to be a part of this historic day
still president-elect biden attending
mass at st matthews cathedral
not everyone who turned up even planned
it i went on a morning walk
and passed this it was like wait a
second um
and yeah we decided to i texted her she
texted me and i ran over and turned over
yeah so we're very excited yeah yeah
very last minute but lucky
yeah there haven't been many complaints
about the security in this city there's
disappointment but also
understanding between the pandemic and
the right of the capital these women say
there's more than enough to worry about
they were out but trying not to be too
close
if we can stay back a little bit and
watch from a distance like we are now
we're across the street we're just kind
of
surveying the area and everything if
anything happens we're gonna go
somewhere else now the streets and
security
say something about the challenges ahead
as now president biden begins his work
he will be busy he will also be
different
he's just a responsible normal
elected leader and i think the country's
ready for that
now there were those who felt on this
day shortchanged that
some sort of a celebration was necessary
something to commemorate the new
president
and the hope that he brings that a page
in history
is turning this should be such a time of
joy
it's really actually devastating that
we're not able to
to celebrate it as we should as
americans
there was for many something not lost on
this day it will happen again
but certainly missed mike armstrong
global news
washington america's allies and enemies
were watching closely to see what tone
president biden would set
he said he had this message for the
world
america has been tested and we've come
out stronger for it
we will repair our alliances and engage
with the world once again
not to meet yesterday's challenges but
today's and tomorrow's challenges
and will lead not merely by the example
of our power but by the power of our
example
the response has been widely positive
the head of the european commission
said today once again after four long
years europe has a friend in the white
house
russia says it hopes for a more
constructive relationship
china says it hopes biden will repair
what it calls serious damage to the
bilateral relationship
and what about canada our ottawa bureau
chief mercedes stevenson joins me now
mercedes what's the reaction from the
trudeau government
well donna the twitter tyranny tariffs
and uncertainty
are over so there's certainly some
relief up here in the canadian
government
but that said it won't all be smooth
sailing with a biden administration
there's no question that justin trudeau
and joe biden
have much more closely aligned
ideologies and key priorities everything
from
anti-racism initiatives to the kind of
economies they want to run
to of course the environment which is a
big issue for both
are likely to see them in sync but today
even we
saw where there's already a hurdle the
cancelling of the keystone xl pipeline
something the trudeau government had
said they were going to fight for
the biden administration wouldn't even
hear them out now in a way that helps
them politically because you can't lose
an argument you didn't make
but on the other hand they can't
characterize biden as being trump-like
and unreasonable
i spoke to foreign affairs minister mark
garneau today
about what this government's plan is for
canadian energy and what he thinks of
the keystone cancellation
it's our understanding that uh that uh
president biden
is going to uh carry through his pledge
uh which made during the campaign to
rescind the permit and uh
we understand we understand that uh and
we respect that
so we will be there of course for the
people
of alberta and we will continue to work
with the united states
uh on the important question of energy
security as we move forward so donna
turns out the trudeau government will
not be continuing to push
on that file another area they could run
into rough seas on
is trade biden faders the buy america
initiative
which favors more protectionist
instincts and could spell trouble for
some canadian industries
and mercedes what about the fate of
michael spavor and michael kovrick
detained in china is it possible that
having biden as president could change
something
well donna that's possible and certainly
a lot of canadians are hoping that that
would be the case
joe biden historically has a closer and
more collaborative relationship with
china
and there's hope he might be able to
convince them to play ball
but at the end of the day he could also
drop the extradition request for mung
wong zhou
of course all of that remains to be seen
donna
all right mercedes in ottawa thanks
donald trump now the former president
is at his resort in florida tonight he
got there before joe biden took the oath
of office
before he left washington trump was
given a final send off at joint base
andrews in maryland
goodbye we love you
we will be back in some form
[Music]
trump appears to be mulling over his
next move according to the wall street
journal he is talking about forming a
new political party called the patriot
party
trump is the first president to be
impeached twice if he is convicted in a
senate trial he could be banned from
ever holding public office
again in one of his last acts as
commander-in-chief
trump granted a flurry of pardons and
commutations
among them his former chief strategist
steve bannon architect of trump's 2016
election win
he was indicted in a scheme to embezzle
money from a group trying to crowdfund
the construction of trump's border wall
and former republican fundraiser elliot
broidy who pleaded guilty to acting as
an unregistered foreign agent in a
scheme to influence trump's
administration
on behalf of interests in china and
malaysia rappers little wayne and kodak
black
were also among those pardoned or had
sentences
commuted seniors waiting for their shot
coming up why some older canadians are
not at the front of the vaccination line
seniors across this country are
wondering when their turn will come to
be vaccinated against covid19
older adults we know are at higher risk
for severe illness from the virus
and each province has its own timeline
for vaccinating seniors who live
independently in the community and not
in long-term care or retirement homes
as mike licoteur explains seniors
advocates say the older adults
should be at the front of the line
regardless of where they live
going for groceries twice a month does
put 84 year old mamie johnson at risk of
catching covet 19.
while she wants the vaccine she's not
upset she'll only get it
in phase two of ontario's rollout
teachers
groceries people um should all be
ahead of me because they see so many
people not everyone feels that way
sylvana finocchio's spirax mother
is in that same age group and she feels
her mom
should be closer to the front of the
line she'll be able to go
two minutes into a grocery store or even
go for a walk outside and not be
terrified
of contracting it the national advisory
committee on immunization
recommends adults who are 70 years and
older
should get the vaccine in stage one of
the rollout
but provinces and territories set their
own schedules and some have that group
getting the shot in the second phase of
vaccination
ageism is showing its ugly head
once again the canadian association of
retired persons points out
over 90 percent of elderly people don't
live in retirement or long-term care
homes
so they're out in the community without
the protection
of a vaccine the risk that they'll
contract covert
is is going to be even greater
and that's causing anxiety among
older canadians geriatricians say all
provinces
should prioritize older populations both
in
and out of care homes if you're actually
going to say that you
want to you know preserve the most life
then you would simply follow the science
and vaccinate
our oldest people first the provinces
and territories say
older canadians are among the top
priorities
but the delivery delay from pfizer buy
in tech
might put a wrench in vaccination
schedules
michael couture global news ottawa
there's some political news out of
ottawa tonight mp derek sloane has been
kicked out of the federal conservative
party
sloan is no longer welcome in caucus
after a majority of
tories voted in a secret ballot to expel
him party leader aaron o'toole initiated
the vote after learning sloan's
leadership campaign had accepted a
donation
from a notorious white supremacist
ahead a new chapter in america
reflections on the ritual
of transferring power
american presidential inaugurations are
always meant to be a showcase of the
peaceful transition of power
there have been 59 of them some during
times of war and political instability
none of them though were like what we
witnessed today
eric sorenson reflects on what's changed
and what stayed the same
on this very spot a shaken democracy
wrapped in a pandemic inside a shattered
economy
there's never been an inauguration like
it the oldest president in american
history
came with the oldest of inaugural
messages it is a time to heal
and for unity history faith and reason
show the way the way of unity
historically a brief but reliable moment
when presidential goodwill
binds a divided nation i thank vice
president gore for a contest
conducted with spirit and ended with
grace
we must do these things together as one
nation
and one people presidents have embraced
this extraordinary occasion to transfer
power peacefully
this every four year ceremony we accept
as normal
is nothing less than a miracle but this
ritual of optimism
was splintered in a single presidency
this
american carnage stops right here
and stops right now president trump
would spend four years fostering
grievances among americans
and when they'd finally had enough he
sulked away in the final hours of his
presidency
the cordial transition from one
president to the next the rides
the handshakes even among bitter rivals
donald trump
couldn't bear it
and so he wasn't there the first
presidential snub of an inauguration
in more than 150 years this is so unique
we're ending a presidency that was like
no other democrats are excited about a
new president and a new start
but i think a lot of it is more uh
relief
and exhaustion that things are getting
back
on track the final gesture of transition
left to vice presidents
where presidents should have stood this
is our historic moment
of crisis and challenge joe biden has
rekindled a spirit of renewal something
to help reassure americans
but they will long remember an
inauguration with flags instead of
crowds
the national guard armed an alert and
the 45th president
who was a no-show as the 46th began his
presidency
eric sorenson global news
next a young american poet with a
passionate plea for unity
you're watching global national
[Music]
there are many memorable moments from
today's inauguration
we want to focus on one that really
stood out america's
youth poet laureate a 22 year old woman
read a poem she wrote called
the hill we climb her name is amanda
gorman she's from los angeles
and it is almost certain we will hear
her clear powerful voice
again here's part of her poem we've
braved the belly of the beast we've
learned that quiet
isn't always peace in the norms and
notions of what
just is isn't always
just this we the successors of a country
and the time were a skinny black girl
descended from slaves and raised by a
single mother
can dream of becoming president
only to find herself reciting for one
we've seen a force that would shatter
our nation
rather than share it would destroy our
country if it meant delaying
democracy and this effort very nearly
succeeded but while democracy can be
periodically delayed it can never
be permanently defeated the new dawn
blooms
as we free it for there is always light
if only we're brave enough to see it if
only we're brave enough to be it
remarkable wisdom remarkable poise that
is global national for this wednesday
january 20th i'm donna friesen
we leave you with more moments from the
inauguration
in washington marking a new era for
america its allies and
the world thanks for watching hope to
see you here again tomorrow
take care of yourselves joseph robinette
biden jr
and dr jill biden
[Applause]
at this sacred time we come before you
in need
indeed on our knees
hi joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly
swear
help you god so help me god
congratulations mr president
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go
you